a what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
it's about time we give the full review
treatment to the Oppo find five so for
those of you who missed it my first
video about this device is on the screen
now and an annotation or it's the first
link below the like button on this video
but to put it bluntly we've been waiting
for this phone for a while this is the
International fine five from Oppo a
company more well known for its pricey
blu-ray players but boy has the thing
been a pleasant surprise in the build
quality department this is the best
smartphone you can buy step aside droid
DNA step aside Samsung plastic step
aside iPhone 5
step aside lumia 920 this is a
stormtrooper of a smartphone build an
absolute boss it measures in at a
hundred sixty five grams in 8.8
millimeters thick so that's actually
making it thinner and lighter than that
920 but not too thin and not too light I
actually prefer a phone that's just a
little bit thicker to accommodate a
bigger battery and they've done that
with this phone it has a 2,500 million
power battery inside the sky so that'll
help it last easily an entire day on a
charge which is nice now I'm not about
to do a drop test but this phone feels
incredibly well built in fact the frame
is made of steel steel there is steel
holding this phone together it has a
rock-solid back to that completes the
look and the bezel around this glass
display it's very hard in glass and it's
pretty sharp around the edges but it is
edge to edge glass so you won't see it
as a scene when you're holding the phone
also if you take a look at the entire
design it's not completely flat on the
top on the bottom it has a little bit of
a curve to the design and has a pretty
traditional button layout which will
remind you that it is definitely still
competing with other high-end
smartphones like a Sony Xperia Z another
1080p phones coming out in the near
future so up on the front you have the
Menu button the home button and the back
button and there is no multitasking
button obviously but we'll get to that
whole process in a second but also just
first off so we're clear the headphone
jack is up top
not my favorite location but it's there
and the audio sounds good and we have
the power button on the left side the
USB port and the microphone on the
bottom and the volume rocker on the
right side now I've been using Motorola
and HTC and Samsung devices for so long
that this power button volume
Rock replacement felt backwards at first
but actually got used to it in a few
days and everything about this design is
great and again it just screams quality
everything about it even the packaging
is awesome
some US manufacturers could really learn
from this very simple clean stylish and
compact packaging and magnetic so it's
really simple even has a subtle design
on the top cover that I actually didn't
notice until I revisited the box a few
days later so this is an awesome box
even the Apple logo SIM card ejector
tool feels high-quality gotta love this
stuff back to the phone anyway on the
back is a pretty decent quality speaker
it actually gets really loud louder than
most other smart phones but it gets
distorted when you crank it that loud
but it's pretty good overall and up top
is a 13 megapixel camera and dual LED
flash and microphone now this camera was
hit or miss really it looks great on the
spec sheet right you know 13 megapixels
but it really just performs like any
other average 8 megapixel smartphone
camera like something like the Optimus G
really sort of middle-of-the-road though
I'm sure this can and will improve with
ah pose constant firmware updates as
they seem really dedicated to updating
it but it takes ok photos it takes HDR
macro the whole nine but I was really
more impressed with the video mode it
actually let me take 1080p HD are videos
which gave me much more dynamic range in
shots that were really bright and really
dark so it seems to do a pretty good job
with that especially for a smartphone
and I was actually most impressed with
the 1.99 pickle meta megapixel
front-facing camera it looked really
good during video calls Google+ Hangouts
so I appreciate the good shooter on the
front but honestly overall clearly the
fine 5 is a unique device that stands
out from the pack especially in the
design and the build quality department
so if you want a phone that's built like
a tank this is your phone no doubt and
when you turn it on hold the crap this
is very different this is a pose skinned
version of Android 4.1 jelly bean now
the immediate first reaction is wow that
looks like a larger and more colorful
stormtrooper iPhone now well you'd be
right I can kind of admit it does look
that way at first this is a me UE
looking skin but then again this is
Android so you don't have to like
everything about these home screens out
of the
you can just throw a Nova Launcher at an
icon pack at whatever widgets you want
and you will never have to see this look
again you don't even have to be rooted
so that's the beauty that runs Android
is very flexible but out of the box this
is what it looks like and it's honestly
a pretty solid experience you can't
really knock it till you try it and
again you do get widgets and all these
things so it's not all just square icons
they've taken some hints from the US
manufacturers like Samsung who don't
just put a skin on it to make it look
different but they actually add value
they add features to make the smartphone
look better or make it more useful so
the notification bar is a perfect
example the Oppo took the opportunity to
add some custom toggles and information
to the notification bar another example
is a multitasking which allows you to
see not one not two but three of your
most recent apps and you can swipe them
away and swipe between them to close
them and you also get an idea of how
much of your two gigabytes of RAM is
free so they've done a pretty good job
with this kind of stuff there's also a
bunch of stock apps that all have a
similar design language among them so
it's kind of unifying the feel among the
apps that come pre-installed on this
phone the only problem with that is that
these are all third-party and when you
start to add other third-party apps from
the Play Store at least the good ones
anyway they all follow Google's new holo
design for Android 4.2 so they're all
blue and dark themed and these apps
might look a little funky on the Oppo
find 5 they might not even fit in really
but even though they don't work or they
do work perfectly and they fit the
platform beautifully that might look a
little out of place web pages look
pretty awesome they are great on the
1080p display and they load pretty
quickly and scrolling and zooming around
it can all be handled by that Snapdragon
s4 pro and Google Chrome is the stock
browser so it's a pretty natural
experience so it's a good job there and
it comes pre-installed with this suite
file manager it's actually good looking
so I'm going to go ahead and use it to
show you the benchmarks that I got on
that Snapdragon s4 pro so yeah in case
you were worried about this skin slowing
down performance nope been synthetic
benchmarks gave it pretty high marks so
you won't have to worry about getting
sluggish or choppy performance or
anything like that this thing flies but
yeah the distinguishing thing about the
software is that all of the
pre-installed bundled apps have that
same white light
and they all look good and beautiful on
that 1080p display and everything but
they might not match your dark hollow
Play Store apps they even though they're
really high quality all the extra
bundled features and the UI tweaks
aren't changed just for the sake of
changing them but they're changed with
the intent of making it better and
making their own software design work on
this device so it's a very Oppo device
as you can see overall I think it flows
pretty well the UI is overall pretty
smooth and I rarely got stuck trying to
figure anything out coming from another
Android device also a question people
want to ask is how well does it keep up
with a power user you know someone like
me who uses their phone every day with
hours of screen on time and I got to say
it kept up pretty well with me I'm a
consistent user and it was really snappy
the whole day maybe not Nexus 4 snappy
but it was acceptable fast and the
battery often lasts me when I get up at
5:30 in the morning don't ask until
around 11:00 or 12:00 at night which
qualifies as a full day in my book and
speaking of screen on time that 1080p
display is of course magnificent for
gaming for using that Snapdragon s4 pro
for watching YouTube videos even it's
beautiful just like the Droid DNA it's a
big bright and nice looking display
viewing angles are also top-notch like
you would expect and it of course blows
the AMOLED displays out of the water in
terms of brightness so the fine 5
handles its business man it's a unique
phone no doubt but it's unique in the
way that makes you want to pick it up
and try it rather than ignore it and
wait for something else and that's
something a boss phone does best build
quality out there and one of the nicest
cleanest designs rivals the buttonless
Galaxy Nexus in terms of sexiness my
opinion and I'm convinced that after all
this time the weight was definitely
worth it alright so there you go guys
that is it that is the Oppo find 5 it's
the Stormtrooper of all smartphones in
terms of design and it is a boss in
terms of build quality so clearly is on
top of at least my list right now for
2013 it's gonna be hard to beat this in
my opinion and definitely in terms of
build I feel like I get a hammer and
nail into wood with this thing and I'd
be more worried about breaking the nail
then I would be about breaking the phone
now I knows how to get a good sense of
how well you would actually like the
phone in person but it definitely feels
like a slightly more Ridge
Lumia 920 it's a little bit lighter a
little bit thinner a little bit sharper
a little bit more handsome and to be
honest on paper this thing is a beast on
the spec sheet it has a 5-inch 1080p
display it has a quad-core Snapdragon s4
pro really good processor probably the
best on the line still right now Android
4.1 jelly bean 2,500 million power
battery 16 gigs of storage 2 gigabytes
of RAM it's it's clearly a a world-class
smartphone and this is aa pose way of
saying hey we can make world-class
smartphones too and they've definitely
proven that so my root my result is I
guess check it out consider it it's one
of the best and it will be for a while
thanks for watching there's been an
mkbhd review video and if you like what
you saw I'll be sure to give it a thumbs
up that really does help out and if you
want to see more videos like this be
sure to subscribe that button is also
below thank you for watching and I'll
talk to you guys the next one peace
you